on en parle avec être clair le jambon
porte parole du quai d'orsay a bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous qu'on
soit c'est une page qui se tourne
aujourd'hui ce retrait de la france au
mali est ce que c'est un échec de la
stratégie militaire française non
absolument pas comme l'expliquait ce
matin le président de la république
c'est une évolution du dispositif qui a
été concertée avec tous nos partenaires
européens et internationaux et africains
bien sûr avec lesquels nous luttons
contre le terrorisme au sahel cette
rivale cette réévaluation du dispositif
elle fait suite à des décisions qui
avaient déjà été prises vous en
souviendrez au sommet de pau au sommet
ne djamena pour faire changer notre
posture sur le terrain avec une emprise
plus légère donc c'est la suite de ceux
de cette évolution pour régionaliser et
sa elysées et pour aussi apporté un
soutien plus fort aux populations
civiles sur le terrain mais s'il n'y a
pas une rupture entre justement ce qui
avait été déclarée à pau en 2020 quand
emmanuel macron a décidé de renforcer le
dispositif militaire au mali et ce
retrait deux ans plus tard anne 15 juin
non absolument pas là la rupture elle
n'est pas de notre fait il y a eu au
contraire une évolution complètement en
phase avec les décisions aux prises à
pois n'djamena avec vous le saviez une
limitation de notre empreinte aux normes
et une civilisation renforcé de notre
action et la décision d'étendre l'action
aussi à l'ensemble de la région puisque
l'on voit que la menace terroriste lcl
s'étend à la fois dans la zone des trois
frontières mais aussi sur le golfe de
guinée la rupture en revanche on l'a vu
du côté de la junte malienne et vous
savez que cette décision elle intervient
aussi dans la suite d'un isolement
croissant de des autorités de transition
malienne qui ont refusé de mettre en
oeuvre les conditions posées par la
cedeao et l'ua et qui aujourd'hui on en
a fait le constat hier soir ne
permettent pas d'effectuer de continuer
d'effectuer ses missions dans les bonnes
conditions emmanuel macron évoque 6 mois
pour ce retrait c'est très rapide
est ce que la france prend un risque
celui d'un retrait chaotique absolument
pas le président l'a prêté six mois
c'est très court il a parlé de deux
retraits ordonnés tout cela a fait
évidemment l'objet d'une planification
extrêmement rigoureuse de 4 à 6 mois
comme il l'a non c est nos militaires
sont en place pour permettre ce retrait
et faire en sorte qu'ils se tiennent
dans de bonnes conditions vous ne
craignez pas donc un retrait précipité
non absolument pas le niger va-t-il
devenir le pays clé pour le
redéploiement des forces françaises
comme l'indiqué le président de la
république nous devons continuer à
lutter contre le terrorisme au sahel ça
c'est vraiment une priorité qui a été
réaffirmé par la france mais par la
totalité des partenaires qui étaient
présents hier soir à paris européens
africains et donc pour lutter contre
cette menace il y à un point de fixation
qui est la zone des trois frontières et
dans ce cadre là les partenaires
européens pourront dégager davantage de
soutien au niger sur cette partie de la
zone mais également au golfe de guinée
est donc cet effort là il va être
redéfini en lien avec les partenaires
africains qu'ils sont les seuls à même
de définir les besoins et vous avez
entendu le président il y aura une
réunion de la coalition celle en mars
qui permettra d'avancer sur ce
dispositif et sa redéfinition la force
européenne takouba aujourd'hui est
totalement remise en question sa
stratégie totalement remise en question
alors l'esprit de taku banon n'est pas
remise en question et je crois que c'est
ça qu'il faut noter c'est à quel point
nous avons contribué avec l'accolade
avec les européens à créer pour la
première fois à une opération de lutte
contre le terrorisme précise qu'elle est
pratiquement mort n'est absolument ça
c'était quand même un succès que
d'arriver à mobiliser tous ses
partenaires autour d'une opération dans
le sahel et tous nos partenaires hier
soir ont bien marqué leur volonté de
continuer à lutter donc ça va se faire
sous de nouvelles formes en réponse aux
besoins exprimés par les pays africains
dans les autres géographique j'ai évoqué
un millier de mercenaires du groupe
bruce wagner se trouve désormais donc au
mali c'est ce que disait jean yves le
drian ce retrait de la france leur les
styles le champ totalement libre non
absolument pas et je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de penser et je crois que c'est
une illusion de l'esprit que de penser
que wagner pourrait être une force de
substitution mais c'est un peu nouveau
forces internationales pas du tout vous
parler de deux mille hommes 2 des
mercenaires de wagner qui sont par
ailleurs une milice privée qui n'ont pas
pour mandat de lutter contre le
terrorisme et qui ont pour mandat de
constituer une grave garde prétorienne
en soutien à des autorités de transition
qui en font finalement leur garantie
pour rester au pouvoir donc la lutte
contre le terrorisme va continuer à se
faire avec les partenaires
internationaux qui eux en ont le mandat
interne il n'y avait pas un déclencheur
wagner tout de même pour la position
française il y avait plusieurs
déclencheur nous l'avons vu il y avait
une rupture politique et ça c'est tout
le refus qui a été celui exprimé aux
autres à la cedeao à l'union africaine
sur lequel on dirait le calendrier de
transition compte totalement rejeté les
autorités de transition et ensuite il y
a eu une rupture
opérationnelle sur le terrain avec toute
une série d' entrave contre les
opérations de la coalition
internationale
vous vous souvenez évidemment du refus
de déploiement du contingent danois dans
le cadre de takouba vous vous souvenez
de la remise en cause des bases légales
même de cette intervention sur le
terrain et wagner participe évidemment
de ces contraintes puisque on voit bien
que une série d entraves qui ont été
mises à la force des nations unies dans
son mandat c'est précisément le survol
au dessus des zones occupées par wagner
wagner justement en rca wagner au mali
est ce que cette force me para
militaires russes pourraient s'installer
ailleurs en afrique cette force
paramilitaire on voit bien qu'elle a à
une stratégie opportuniste hic elle elle
utilise les fragilités politique de
certains états pour s'établir pour se
livrer à une oeuvre de prédation et
d'exactions et c'est évidemment
complètement incompatible avec tous les
efforts de la communauté internationale
est ce qu'on peut dire que la france a
échoué dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
allumant pas je crois qu'il faut revenir
comme le président l'a fait sur
l'historique du déploiement français au
sahel et aux manies 2013 l'intervention
serval a permis d'éviter que bamako ne
tombe sous les coups des groupes
djihadistes servent à l'insuccès barkan
un échec ou par cana succès barkan dans
la g dans la continuité de cerval à
continuer à faire ce travail les
ces leaders des groupes terroristes on
parle d'aqmi on parle de l'état
islamique qui ont été neutralisés dans
le cadre de ses opérations et donc tout
l'infrastructure de ces groupes
terroristes qui a été fragilisée donc la
menace et aux russes elles restent mais
elle était diminuée dans son dans son
caractère territorial il ya un an nous
avons permis d'éviter que le mali ne
devienne un émirat jihadistes et que
bamako ne tombe entre ses ça va être le
dessin animalier à présent un émirat
nous n'espérons pas bien sûr et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous
continuerons à agir en soutien des
populations maliennes et cela reste un
des objectifs qui a été réaffirmé par
nos partenaires et donc nous
continuerons à le faire dans le cadre de
la coalition celle qui vous le savez a
renforcé son action au soutien des
populations mais les menaces terroristes
aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble de l'afrique
de l'ouest on parle maintenant
effectivement d'autres pays qui seraient
touchés par cette menace c'était plus
seulement le mali fait seulement le
sahel non vous avez vu un
un trait le bénin on arrête romaine un
absolument et donc explique bien et
pourquoi nous devons redéfinir ce
dispositif et à apporter notre appui à
tous les laits de tous les pays côtiers
au sud du mali qui ont besoin de cet
appel de cet appui international
est ce qu'il ya des leçons à tirer de
ces neuf ans d'intervention en france de
cette présence française est ce que
aujourd'hui on se dit que finalement la
présence militaire française trop
longtemps dans un pays que ce soit la
france qui soit aux états unis en
afghanistan
c'est un problème ça ne fonctionne pas
non je ne crois pas il faut regarder un
petit peu l'évolution qu'a eue 7,7 ce
dispositif en fait on est dans un
mécanisme d'adaptation permanente à la
fois à la menace terroriste mais aussi
aux conditions politiques et donc si
vous regardez depuis 2000 13 et u serval
barkan nous avons créé à la fois
l'alliance elle qui a permis aussi
d'apporter un soutien international aux
populations civiles et de ne pas traiter
uniquement le problème du point de vue
sécuritaire mais aussi politique est ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui mais c'est sûr
nous avons dit là et c'était vraiment
une des conclusions du sommet de peau et
de n'djamena que de conclure à la
nécessité d'une coalition en quatre
piliers et donc ces deux autres piliers
nous allons continuer à les porter et
c'était aussi un désengagement qui a été
pris hier soir merci beaucoup merci
locaux en clair le genre dans d'avoir
été avec nous porte parole du quai
d'orsay on va tout de suite à